a Minnesota grandmother accused of
murder in two states is the focus of a
nationwide search this morning police
believe 56 year-old Louis Reese killed
her husband David and then killed a
woman who looked like her to steal the
woman's identity police say this newly
released surveillance video shows Reese
and the woman in a florida restaurant
just days before her victim was found
dead tonita copal is here with new
details of the search Tony good morning
good morning what a search it is
investigators consider Louis Reese to be
armed and dangerous and for weeks she's
led police and u.s. marshals on a
pursuit stretching from Minnesota to
Florida and now Texas where police fear
she could kill again she is armed and
she is dangerous she looks like anyone's
mother or grandmother and she's a killer
the face of a nationwide manhunt is a 56
year old grandmother from rural
Minnesota we don't know exactly where
she is she could be anywhere at this
time police in Florida say Louis Reese
was at this Fort Myers brewery on April
5th they say surveillance video from
inside shows Reese for friending her
alleged victim 59 year-old Pamela
Hutchinson four days later police found
Hutchinson dead in her Florida condo
carmine marcinho is with the local
sheriff's office further investigation
revealed that Miss Hutchinson was
targeted by the suspect due to the
similarities and their appearance
police believe Reese quickly assumed
Hutchinson's identity stealing her
credit cards and driver's license and
fleeing in her white Acura family
members say they're not surprised to
hear Hutchinson was targeted my cousin
went out helping the world she'd
befriended this woman probably the woman
probably gave her some sob story
she took her in she's just giving to a
fault to her death police have been
looking for recent late March when they
discovered her husband David Reese dead
of multiple gunshot wounds in the
couple's rural Minnesota home missing
mr. Reese's white Cadillac and $11,000
illegally transferred from his bank
accounts from Minnesota Reese allegedly
drove to Iowa stopping at different
casinos before continuing on to Fort
Myers police say she was most recently
spotted in Corpus Christi Texas where
investigators fear she could cross the
border into Mexico as her resources go
away
she may strike again so everyone must
use extreme caution and help us and
assist us to bring this fugitive to
justice and police say Rhys has a
history of gambling problems the
Minneapolis star-tribune that's her home
state paper says court records reveal
Reis had been accused of stealing more
than 78,000 dollars from her disabled
sister and spent thousands of it at
casinos now get this police also believe
Rees used the same gun in both killings
and she may still have it this is very
serious I'm glad you're doing this right
now everybody knows what she looks like
indeed hopefully it won't take long to
catch her indeed and she's a grandmother
it means her grandchildren out there so
I can't something about her family yes
thank you Tony Cole Buddha's right